title of my
sex tape a stinky mud paddle to you and
me
also you might expect us to send bodies
of water under water but with the right
viscosity and density something like
this is totally possible
so instead i'll send these changing
tents where people apparently change
into swimwear
that they probably should have already
been wearing since they are always under
the water
laying out on the beach when you're at
the bottom of the ocean and what do you
even need the umbrellas for
hey sandy who am i sandy never answers
this question so i'll take the steel and
go with helmet head phallic nose
do i get the points hello spongebob
tom kenny impersonating roger bumpus's
squidward is top notch
in fact this whole incredible voice cast
deserves a sin off and we always give
people what they deserve
even if i combine that spongebob is a
master sand sculptor which for the
record i do not
how is he making the doorbell sound or
the telephone ring
did anyone order 20 pepperonians hand
pizzas i hope not because you're 11
short
thinking random beach lifters would have
an audience of 18 in the stands
i mean 15 sure but 18. if these weights
are straight above sandy's head and
sandy is wearing a spherical air helmet
then who shut off physics
show is a dick to the poly exclusion
principle also can we talk about how odd
competitions like this are
simply being the person who can lift the
most weights proves what exactly
still more exciting than soccer though
y'all watch this i would love to sandy
but that anchor weight was nowhere to be
seen a second ago so i'd rather watch
the wizarding powers you used to make it
appear
wearing john lennon's sunglasses as a
bikini top sucking the marshmallow right
off the stick
not sure if i'm more traumatized by the
germs or the splinters or my boner
look spongebob knew what happened when
he heard that rip and you can't see them
any better from this angle
so why would he turn his sponge buns
toward the crowd he deserves all the
laughter he gets
ain't he the funniest little sponge you
ever saw this could very well be true
but is there a lot of competition
okay here it comes sandy throws this
disc at a severely upward angle yet
somehow still paul macbeth spongebob
right in the face with a straight-up
park job
and if that weren't crazy enough just a
gentle reminder have you ever tried
throwing a disc
under water i'll take a banana split
eating a banana split underwater or
really eating any food soaked in salt
water
i bet spongebob has so many kidney
stones
not pictured lamode did you order 20
cases of
pans spongebob stole this idea while
visiting a lonely nearby island
it's his rip in a box there goes
spongebob
gripping his pants again in fact that's
the eighth time
exactly how many pairs of pants did
spongebob bring to the beach today
but also he's actually surfing and doing
it well
at least for a second so why isn't that
being talked about
why that wasn't funny spongebob you all
had me worried sick
using y'all to refer to one person you
think you're being cute the south but i
swear if one of you calls me honey or
identifies my dr pepper as a coke again
i'm confiscating all your peach cobbler
for the next 20 years
oh no everybody's gone if by gone you
mean they're less than 100 feet away
from you then
yes i guess that checks
on the out danny boyle impersonations
all just because i
ripped my pants well guess i'm never
unseeing that since he's such a good
performer one wonders why didn't just
whip his giant singing ability out of
his pants when he was desperate for
attention
sponge nude eunuch pants
don't let people see your butt it's your
butt sinners go vows to our newest
domain of nitpick delights and behold
sins oh and subscribe immediately so the
order goes click
sub simple as that oh actually watch the
video jesus i guess i need to make a
flow chart commercial sends go now
hey sandy who am i
why do you keep see seeing me on things
that have nothing to do with me
could i borrow a couple of these careful
ethan your s'more is burning
i got it i got it i got it
i ain't got it that was too funny
all i need are some tasty waves cool
buzz
and i'm fine i guess i ripped my pants
again
we are laughing this is the last chance
if katrina can hit this
pressure putt that's the only way and it
is
true right in the middle keep going
partner
you shot all the bad guys save your
strength buddy
how about a last cigarette i need
i need give me give me give me i need
i need i thought that i had everybody on
my side
but i went and blew it all sky
high